what's coming to fallout 76
[Applause]
hi I'm project leader Jeff Gardner and
I'm Co studio director Tom Mustaine on
behalf of everyone at Bethesda Game
Studios
we want to thank the millions of you who
have played with us stuck with us and
helped shape the world a fallout 76
absolutely
it's incredible what the game has become
you've told us how much you've loved
this year's updates so far from camp
building legendary weapons player
vending and of course the dreaded
sheepsquatch we've also been working on
our biggest update yet
it's called wastelanders and it will
fundamentally change the game it's been
some time since both 76 opened its door
[Applause]
and we all discovered that Appalachia
isn't quite what it used to be we
encountered a lot of things overcame a
lot of things I don't think any of us
expected for people to actually come
back are you from that vault can you
help us
we've traveled pretty far there there's
hope here in Appalachia folk rebuilding
fighting battle will fight to right by
your side
we've been everywhere and seen
everything and the one thing we've
learned is this
you've got to claim the wasteland before
it claims you
question is are you with us with them
[Applause]
that's right that's right human NPCs are
coming to Fallout 76 not just NPCs but a
full quest line new rewards and as you
saw full dialogue trees
this is a long-term story we're telling
year one was about the vault doors
opening and all of you settling the
wasteland year two is about people
coming back to reclaim it like previous
Fallout games these characters have
their own stories and goals it's up to
you to choose how to interact with them
and live with those consequences the
wastelanders update is coming this fall
and will be free for all fallout 76
players
and in the spirit of free we're doing
something special just for III fallout
76 is going to have a free trial for
everyone starting tomorrow
that's right it's that's right it's the
perfect time to see what fallout 76 and
its growing community have become we
can't wait to welcome all of you and
because so many of you are going to be
joining us
we thought we'd also give you a sneak
peek this week at an all new game-mode
check it out your first test was making
it to the vault now your real trial
begins currently there is no overseer of
vault 51 perhaps you will be the one
we are in serious need of leadership so
uh I have devised a unique process of
elimination rows battle to the death is
the only sure way to judge the superior
candidate this should prove interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there could only be one overseer good
luck
[ __ ] yeah we put a battle royale in
fallout 76 right nuclear winter is a
battle royale born from the Fallout
universe from power armor to perk cards
from camp building to contending with
wasteland creatures and of course my
personal favorite nukes it's a great
free addition to an already huge game we
love playing it and we think you will
too
so check out the sneak peak and let us
know what you think remember all of
fallout 76 including nuclear winter is
free to try this week on all platforms
so jump in tomorrow we can't wait to see
you thanks again
[Applause]